I don't know maybe hair got in too deep
and mixed up the wrong crowd that kind
of thing
you can talk to humans I can talk to
Pokemon and if you want to find your
pops we're gonna need you no I don't
need a Pokemon what about a world-class
detective
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
out of your friends and family what are
they having the most fun with hearing
your voice coming out of that Deadpool
costume we're hearing it coming out of a
Pikachu alright I gotta say at this
point because Pokemon characters are for
whatever reason are like like actual
catnip to children so they as soon as
they saw a detective Pikachu just the
test models that they send me cuz they
do that thing or they're like let's send
him a Pikachu paired to his voice let's
do a really good job animating the face
let's make it look super real and I know
he's gonna show his kid so of course
like I opened up my laptop and then I
minute my kid walks - she's just like
that is amazing
like like please inject that right into
my eyeballs for the rapport all time so
that's kind of what happened and then I
was just in you know I didn't know that
much about it I had to learn everything
fast you know you've always been great
at comedic timing your entire career but
I feel like of late your voice more so
than your dashing movie star looks like
you're Eric well it's been like a hot
commodity you know your voice has has
that changed the way you've approached
acting or thought about acting that your
voice now is this hot commodity I don't
know I I mean I I never imagined myself
as a voice actor ever but I love
creating characters and and if I can do
something where my face isn't featured
great because I'm you know on the inside
I'm just another you know self-loathing
you know masochistic you know a hold
it's like trying to crush his inner self
so yeah I mean it's I like that I like
hiding behind do you feel free or you
feel like I think for everyone right you
know people talk like would that that
thing with a super could you would you
if you could pick a superpower is it
flying or is it invisibility you know
that's it's tricky Pokemon companions
big theme in this film so of course I
have to ask you Ryan Reynolds has his
own pokeyman companion mm-hmm what does
it look like what are its traits
I had a Pokemon like my own like if I
could be one it would definitely be a
Snorlax cos like wow man to get like
shot I just on a moment's notice like
that I'm great but I love for squirtle
squirtle looks like a little like a
really cute kind of
adorable precious alcoholic it wanders
around with you all day it's not unlike
having a toddler Tim you untied was a
legend in this precinct if you are
anything like your talent
I remember you wanted to be a pokémon
trainer anyway yeah yeah they didn't
really work out come in there whoever
you are
and not to use this
geez here we go I know you can't
understand me but put down the stapler
or I will electrocute you I've heard
that you are a Pokemon fan coming into
this movie yeah so here's the question
I'm gonna give you if somebody is not as
familiar with Pokemon what would you say
sort of like a cheat sheet like either
do this or do that before the movie or
do this do that after the most
interesting as a good question um I feel
like a lot of people at least know what
Pokemon is I'm just I find it hard to
believe that people don't know what it
is all right like know what color
Pikachu is or know the theme song or the
the the log line or something but if
there is that one person out there who
doesn't know if how c'mon is I think
that the movie does a really good job of
of establishing the universe making sure
that you're not completely lost when you
come anyway who are these magical
creatures and also providing you with a
relatable story at the the center of the
film which is you know a young man
trying to reconcile with his father so I
really don't think it's necessary to
know a lot about Pokemon but definitely
after watching the film you hopefully
would be come a fan you know III saw
this movie with some kids and I asked
them I was like what's the first
question that you would have for the
folks that are in the movie coming out
of it and the thing that they were most
interested in is when you're holding the
Pikachu picking up the Pikachu and the
Pikachu's on your shoulders and what are
you carrying are you holding a real
animal you what what do they have in
your hands so sometimes it's a stunt
Pikachu that it has a neck that moves
and arms that move and sometimes it's
just a green blob and that like it looks
like a faceless armless Pikachu
essentially and then sometimes there was
the same kind of amorphous blob but with
fur so you could see my fingers in the
in the texture of the fur the kids film
is a lot about Pokemon companions that's
a big theme in this movie if you
yourself had a Pokemon companion what
Pokemon would it be what would it
straight
well I I'm I have a favorite Pokemon
which is Totodile from generation to is
a water-type pokemon he's a dragon and
he's really cool and I used to play use
him in the games I don't like when I was
a kid in Pokemon cold so he would
probably be my pokémon partner and why
do people need to go see this movie on
the big screen well I mean just this
this the special effects team did an
amazing job in addition to Rob did an
amazing job of creating this universe
for the first time you're seeing this
universe in live-action you know that
it's never been done before
so I think it's important to see on a
big screen just to get that scope just
to get all of those details and textures
that that you've that we haven't seen
before
yeah I mean is it's it's meant to be
experienced in all of its cinematic
glory now obviously I've done what this
pups before so I'll just do it again hey
what do you know I can't do when people
are watching
[Music]
all right so coming on to this film did
you need a pokeymon crash course and if
so what does a crash course in Pokemon
look yeah I needed a pokémon trainer
encyclopedia I needed seven experts no I
was a fan before but it didn't matter
because when you're making a Pokemon
film you want to be perfect you know
what I mean you wanted to be perfect I
mean I think I for like half the film I
was saying pokemons and we had Pokemon
experts on set and finally they were
like Catherine it's Pokemon I was like
oh my god so then you know an 80-yard
Pokemon Pokemon
ADR fix it you got to fix it that's how
much we cared I mean kind of should
prepare again our hair and makeup
trailer we had all the peak like not all
of them a ton like up against the wall
so every day you know you learn you
learn another and you learn another
there's so much in this universe that
I've yet still to find out you know you
know and spending as much time as you
have in this universe you know the
Pokemon are beloved around the world
what do you think it is about them that
just make them so beloved so addicting I
mean maybe it's cuz the game is
addicting I don't know I don't know well
I also think it's a shared experience
you know like are you a fan of Pokemon a
little a little bit but I mean your
experience it's still something that we
share so I think maybe bad that's why I
love movies I am I like sharing that
human experience of even just going to
the cinema you know yeah so when dating
you're always looking for somebody who
is your type Pokemon are classified by
type waterFire very so using Pokemon
classifications what would you say your
type is uh for a person Oh
psychic dangerous so Pokemon companions
are a big theme in this film if you had
your own pokemon companion what would
you say it would be like I would
probably pick Charizard because I you
know maybe like I could get a lift
sometimes like through the air
and why do you think people need to see
this on the big screen oh you need to
see it on the big screen because there's
a lot of detail we also shot it on film
not a lot of people know that I mean
like and when a movie is on film it just
is a little more beautiful it's just
beautiful so um I think you just will
like it more I've been watching so many
things like on my iPad you know and it's
just not the same experience I like when
you're in a theater and you escape this
movie is an escape and it's so much
magic so just go have fun you know yeah
and if you had to pick a Pokemon to
co-star with in your next movie who oh
well okay mmm I can't I can't get rid of
Psyduck but I would have to maybe like
add a furfrou because I'm a poodle and a
furfrou is like this poodle pokémon I
feel like it has to be in the sequel
you